uh good morning so we've just heard
michael go spelling out his scheme to
house uh ukrainian refugees is that
something you support well look we've
all seen the terrible images from
ukraine
and you know families fleeing for the
border fling for their lives and so um
you know i do think the uk has to play
its part
so far i think the home office and the
government's got it completely wrong the
scheme that they've put in place so far
has been too slow
too narrow
to mean
and you know we're where we were
essentially with afghanistan which is
only acting in the heat of the moment
now
do i think that you know where possible
people should play their part in britain
yes and i'm sure that many of the
british public will be incredibly
generous and welcoming
what would comfort me more frankly is if
i heard from michael gove that there are
plans in place for the support that's
actually going to be needed on arrival i
know that when
i was dealing with some of the afghan
families that arrived in my own
constituency during the course of the
summer
what i saw there is what i think we will
see in relation to ukraine
refugees which is traumatized families
desperately in need of support desperate
to know what's happening to their
relatives back in ukraine he seems to be
suggested just hit me out on this and
i'll come straight back um needing the
support in terms of schooling work etc
but that's what he said
he did say that and he said that there
would be ten thousand pounds per
individual made available to local
authority areas that that that is the
support you're talking about that's a
good thing but if if the government was
announcing now those plans in um hard
edge form i would have much more comfort
in them
local authorities have been consulted
that the advice is being set up what i
saw in the summer was you know
saying that the money is going to go to
local authorities ten thousand parents
he is but those plans just need to be in
place now so i'm not against the scheme
that he is proposing
i have to say the more you questioned
him the more i queried exactly how it's
going to work um but actually i'd have
more comfort
if
there was a solid plan on the table
local authority leaders are saying that
they haven't been consulted yet um they
are there ready to put the support in
housing providers need to be uh involved
in this well exactly what exactly are
you
what exactly are you asking for because
you want a concrete plan on the ground
it feels like there is a concrete plan
now
well i'm not sure sorry about that
because
what i saw in the summer was you need
language experts you need experts with
traumatized families you need experts
who can help them contact their
relatives back in the country they've
just fled from you need people who can
sort out schooling very quickly you need
a local authorities completely engaged
in it and you need housing providers
that can all be done and it was done in
the summer i would just like the
reassurance of knowing that plan is in
place i'm not against um you know where
families can
housing a refugee of course i'm not
against that um but i do think the basic
support needs to be put in and i want to
hear from michael gove that those plans
are fully ready and i'm hearing on the
ground that that just isn't the case
across the country so what is labour's
um proposal for
refugees then you're talking about
involving local authorities um involving
local housing providers would you like
to see an uncapped number of refugees
coming from ukraine without visas to be
housed here what i want to see is very
simple it's a simple safe route to
sanctuary for those that are fleeing for
their lives no one would disagree with
that statement no well
nobody would disagree that's not a
concrete plan like you want in the
government nobody would disagree with
that but we haven't seen that in recent
weeks what the government has put in
places
to our country what's the concrete plan
that you would like to see then we want
emergency protection visas very simple
very straightforward that could be dealt
with on route on advice centers on route
to the united kingdom so that by the
time people are here they can come
straight in the country get the support
that they need very simple very
straightforward should have been thought
through weeks and months ago
the likelihood of an invasion of ukraine
was known weeks ago the home office has
been far too slow far too mean in
relation to this and and frankly the
last few weeks have been an
embarrassment for the united kingdom in
the way that it's dealt with refugees
would you like to see an uncapped number
of these emergency visas well sorry i'm
not going to pluck a number out the air
in the middle of this conflict we can
all see what's happening in you no i'm
not asking
i understand and but i'm just saying
would you like to see a cap on the
number or would it be uncapped i think
that we need to work with our allies
across europe in a coordinated way and
the uk has to play its part i heard
michael gove say tens of thousands
i think plucking a number is wrong we
don't know where this conflict is going
to go we all hope that it de-escalates
but we don't know that and therefore
anybody today putting a number on it i
don't think it's being real i'm not
asking for a number i'm asking if it
should be capped or not that's quite
different well no i don't think it
should be a cap is a number
no cap then
a cap is a number and i'm not going to
i'm not asking you i'm not asking you
whether what the number should be but
i'm asking if if there should be a cap
or it should be uncapped we should
provide sanctuary to all of those that
are fling for their lives um that uh
want to come to the united kingdom and
play our full part it shouldn't be
capped it shouldn't be captured okay
thank you uh right i'm we've obviously
seen more
it almost feels relentless doesn't it
the horrors that we've seen
coming out of ukraine um the uk says
that they're supplying defensive weapons
but ukrainians want to see more military
weapons fighter jets and so on they've
obviously asked for a no-fly zone
do you think the uk needs to be doing
more at this point
we
the labour party in the opposition have
been supportive of the government on the
in-principle stand
um standing up to russian aggression and
standing up for the ukrainian people
what
putin wants more than anything is
division he wants nato to be divided he
wants our allies to be divided and he
wants us back here in the united kingdom
be to be divided politically we won't
let that happen
um because i think
um on an issue as important as this we
have to stand together so where the
government has provided military
equipment into ukraine we have supported
that
where we've said the government needs to
go further and faster is in relation to
sanctions
those sanctions frankly should have been
in place before this evasion started
there was a russia report of two years
ago that set out
all the problems and why we needed
sanctions the economic crime bill was
talked about a year ago it's only now
coming on the statute book so i want the
government to go further and fast on
sanctions we will vote for those
measures by the way but i do want the
government to go further on humanitarian
aid refugees i think the home office so
far has got it completely wrong i think
everybody knows they've got it
completely wrong and we need to see
change so we are supportive in principle
on the things that really matter we want
to push the government further and
faster where they're simply not going
fast enough i was trying to get a sense
from michael gove about any red lines
whether the uk response would change or
particularly on the use of chemical
weapons it feels like that is a very
real fear for people
if putin uses chemical weapons a clearly
a war crime is that a point when the
military response from the uk nato
potentially but the uk needs to escalate
there is always the
chilling risk of escalation that none of
us want to see
i think in the middle of a conflict like
this we shouldn't be speculating in the
what ifs
we have to work in lockstep
with our nato allies responding as
things develop but at this stage
discussing what if i don't think is
helpful in a in a conflict like that
even if it could act as a deterrent
potentially there right well at the
moment we have to be absolutely clear
providing military equipment the
strongest possible sanctions and i'm
talking about sanctions that don't just
um you know isolate russia but
[ __ ] russia's ability to function
that's why i want the government to go
further and faster but i think that
sitting in tv studios speculating
if putin does this
then um we we will do that i don't think
that's the role at the moment that has
to be something that's agreed in
lockstep with our nato allies
there are huge implications
of any escalation and
i think we should respond as this
develops what i want to see is obviously
a ceasefire
and the um withdrawal of uh russian
troops from ukraine you know uh that is
what we all want to see and that's what
the measures we're taking are designed
to achieve do you think there's any hope
obviously aspire i mean there's
obviously talks going on are you
optimistic that there could be
some kind of negotiated deal i'm not
optimistic because it's very difficult
to see what the basis of any agreement
could be
but of course if it is possible to
achieve a ceasefire and a withdrawal by
russia then of course like everybody
else i would want that to happen
the shocking images i didn't think in my
lifetime
i would ever see again russian
tanks rolling into a european country
soldiers kissing their children goodbye
as they stay to defend their cities and
their country
and families fleeing for their lives the
awful bombing of a maternity hospital of
course if it's possible to find a way
through this then we should all be uh
hoping for that but am i optimistic no
i'm afraid not at the moment yeah it's
it's absolutely heartbreaking as you say
with your lawyer's hat on it is vladimir
putin a war criminal yes yes what i've
seen already amounts to war crimes
particularly uh the awful attacks on
civilians
and i think it's very important that
he's held to account and is responsible
and all those that are acting with him
know that they too will be held to
account and this is something which we
need to make clear now
um so that those who are involved at the
moment know what the consequences are
there's a gap that we've got to plug and
that is in relation to the aggression of
the invasion that is not something that
at the moment can be dealt with by
international tribunals which is why i
and others have suggested that we set up
a tribunal to deal with this bit like
the nuremberg tribunal so that the act
of aggression itself the aggressive
invasion that's going on is itself
something for which putin and everybody
who is acting with him can be held to
account for um i want to talk to you
about lord lebado theme yeah newspaper
proprietor son of a former kgb uh agent
um we spoke to michael goverley he said
no one had raised any security concerns
with him about him over the years and
that we shouldn't fall into the trap of
effectively demonizing people from
russia what's your response to that
well of course we shouldn't just
demonise people from russia i completely
agree with that but that isn't the leber
dev case
the
media today are saying there were
further reservations by the security and
intelligence services which were known
before this appointment was made
and we know that um concerns were raised
apparently with the prime minister now
in light of the revelations today or the
further revelations today i think the
prime minister's got serious questions
to answer what did he know
um and did he override security advice
um i've already suggested that
um there needs to be a process here to
look into this appointment um the
intelligence and security committee
could look into it obviously that's a
matter for them but there needs to be a
process but i think the lord's
appointments commission as well i've
written to them to say um in the
exceptional circumstances of this case
where there were security issues in
relation to an appointment by the prime
minister to the house of lords will they
release the advice or the information
they were giving and will they review
the appointment because
um the more
that the media probe into this the more
serious the reservations it appears of
the security and intelligence services
and the more the judgment of the prime
minister is called into question the
judgment the prime minister called into
question what exactly are you saying
that he did wrong here well that's why i
want to process because i haven't seen
the materials
almost certainly confidential by their
nature but i don't think we can sit back
when there were
revelations that we've seen in our
papers today about these security
concerns in relation to lebadov and say
oh well the appointment's been made it
doesn't really matter this is a question
of national security let us have a
process to look into what actually
happened what did the prime minister
know
um and what did he do in response to
that and i think that's the least that
we're entitled to in relation to this
appointment
um i want to talk a little bit about
what's happening here in the uk because
things are going to get let's be frank
really difficult for people um you'll
have noticed it if you've filled your
car up recently uh with energy bills
increasing there's going to be an awful
lot of people faced with that terrible
choice between effectively heating their
homes and eating yeah what's the big
idea from the leader of the opposition
to try and ameliorate the biggest cost
of living crisis that we could have seen
for decades well the first thing is this
is not
um
only caused by the invasion of ukraine
this predates we were in a cost of
living crisis before russia invaded
ukraine so this has been something
that's been on the cards for a very long
time so what's the um what we've said is
do something now to deal with the energy
bills that people are facing as
everybody knows
most people are going to face an energy
bill rise of about 700 pounds in just a
few weeks time
and now with what's happened
internationally there's likely to be
another thousand pounds or so in the
autumn so we the labour party have said
take action what we would do
is have a windfall tax on the oil and
gas companies in the north sea who have
made more profit than they expected
because of the global price and you just
trust them to pass on them to consumers
more in their own words more money than
they know what to do with use that to
reduce the energy bills for households
by up to 600 pounds for those
particularly in need so a very direct
act that we would do
the government says no no no no we don't
want to ask any more of the oil and gas
companies we will ask working families
um and families to do it instead we'll
give them a loan
is there a worry they will give them a
loan of 200 which they will then pay
back over the next few years so the
political divide here is huge we say oil
and gas companies have to pay their part
particularly when they've had profits
they didn't expect the government says
we're going to hammer working families
but at the same time at the same time is
there not a concern firstly that this
windfall tax will not necessarily be
passed on to consumers but also that it
could almost act as a distance
to invest more in oil out of the north
sea at a time when we are facing big
questions about our energy security in
the uk these are windfall taxes these
are taxes on profits that those
companies did not expect to make the
global price has been higher than they
had anticipated therefore they've made
more profit than they anticipated they
have said they've used expressions such
as we've got more money than we know
what to do with the argument the
government has well we won't touch that
instead we'll ask families okay to foot
the bill by having a loan that they
don't want and paying it off is a it
just shows the complete difference in
priorities of the labour party that
wants to look after families who've got
energy bills they can't afford and the
government that's putting even more
pressure on those families boris johnson
reportedly going to saudi arabia next
year to talk about and getting oil
potentially moral potentially from there
there's obviously big human rights
concerns about saudi arabia are you
comfortable with us relying more on
saudi arabia for our energy if we're
trying to stop the use of russian oil if
i were the prime minister i would have a
uh
an energy strategy
here in the uk
i just want to get a clear answer well
there are human rights of course the
human rights issues
the direct question is should we be
accepting uh more oil from saudi arabia
we need an energy security strategy for
the uk i thought i'm really not clear
but i'm really i'm really just answering
me out and then i we need an uh an
energy strategy for the uk that's been
lacking for 10 years what i would like
to see is an energy strategy that's
based on the uk
not so reliant on other countries saudi
arabia or other countries one of the
things we've learned in the last few
years and particularly in the last few
weeks and months of over reliance
on international imports energy now
aren't we should we be looking to get
more energy from saudi arabia right now
what is it if there's anything not if
there's anything could be done to bring
the price down now then
so
well well you say okay the problem with
energy strategy is we've always done the
short term over the last 12 years and we
are where we are we need to have a
strategy that you know
fast forwards on nuclear doubles our
wind capability onshore increases it
offshore develops hydrogen and actually
has a plan to insulate our homes to
bring the whole price of energy i want
an energy um strategy which is secure
and makes us less reliant on what
happens abroad and therefore if this is
a short-term measure to bring down
prices well that's one thing if it is a
long-term strategy to make us dependent
on saudi arabia instead of russia then i
would take a fundamentally different
approach okay that makes sense um now
talking about sanctions which you have
done before chelsea football club
obviously been hit by these crippling
sanctions because of their owner roman
avranovich they're not even allowed to
sell tickets today they are playing
newcastle united and who obviously been
owned by a group led by saudi arabia's
sovereign wealth fund you're a football
fan yourself do you think this should be
a watershed moment for football to look
at how it's funded yes i think that
moment has passed we've had a review
tracy crouch a conservative mp who's
respected across the house has carried
out that review
um and i think the government now needs
to act on it so yes this is in very
sharp focus now but actually the need to
look again at governance in football has
been there for a very long time now okay
a very quick question i just thought you
might better clear up and there's
something
some people were slightly confused about
whether you're still calling for the
prime minister to resign at the minute
or because of ukraine you've withdrawn
that call
what is the position on that do you
think boris johnson should resign
i haven't changed my mind on boris
johnson i think he's lost the moral
authority to lead i don't think he's fit
to be our prime minister
um i can't force him to resign only tory
mps can do that
but i have to say that just at the
moment my total focus is on the ukraine
and what we have to do in response to
the russian aggression there and i think
everybody would understand why my focus
is on that vital issue just at the
moment yeah of course uh kirst dharma
labour leader thank you very much for uh
coming on the program today's much
appreciated thank you